tropicana field in tampa saint pete
ready for our first of three between the
angels and the defending ale champion
tampa bay rays
ohtani a left-handed hitter hitting 265
with 23 home runs
a ball in his strike to shohei four
homers on the home stand
and a home run here in tampa st beat
that didn't take long
oh man too sexy for the cat walk
[Applause]
one-nothing halos gotcha for show hey
that home run his 24th of the season
it's the seventh homer that he's hit in
the last nine games
and right out of the blocks on this
friday night
it's showtime here's anthony rendon
here's a pitch that rendon hits high and
deep and that one is gone
he just hit one out as well down the
left field side anthony rendon
who was two for his last 19. hits a home
run
and the angels have hit a pair of them
here in the very first inning and it's
now two to nothing
griffin canning going out there the 25
year old right-hander coming in for his
13th appearance 12th start
of the year it's been a little bit of a
struggle for him he does have the five
wins which leads the staff
for the angels but the era at 507. the
raise
down two now they get their first two
men aboard 2-2
and he shoots it into left field ward
goats back
and that ball is going to be off his
glove
diaz is going to score joy will go to
third
and bronco winds up at second base
it's 2-1 as taylor ward has one plank
off
his mitt for an error that's going to
drop but mays head into left-center
field
joey scores to tie it bronco's headed to
the plate
he is safe and out at
take a three to two lead andrew
kittredge opening act is done two
innings two hits two runs earned
lines one into left field that's gonna
roll all the way out to the wall
this will be extra bases as david
fletcher will coast in the second base
and he has a lead off double for the
angels that's his 12th of the year
01 on shohei and he drops a bunt down on
the first base side this is a good bun
and he has a blunt hit
fletch the third and the angels are in
business with runners at the corners
so here's walsh at the plate now still
runners at first and third he swings at
the first pitch bounces this one to choi
fires to the plate and the ball pops off
the mid of the catcher mejia
otherwise fletcher might have been out
so the angels catch a break and the game
is tied at three
nothing really seems to bother josh
there's a swing and a fly ball right
center field should be playable
phillips and karemi with a jump ball is
going to be phillips to catch it
and this side is retired so one run
scores
and the pitch reached four and another
comebacker josh had to come off the
bound to get this one turns and fires
over the first
for the second out swinging at one
hopper to yandy at 30 with shallow he
reaches up to get it and throws to first
for the out a nice
three ground ball inning two right back
to josh and the angels go down one two
three middle to the fourth
that's a liner into right gonna fall for
a base hit
kermeyer is aboard for the first time
tonight with that one out
single way up and there's
ball four so with his attention divided
he walks mejia on four pitches and that
pushes kiermeier
into scoring position the next 3-2 pitch
to phillips
got him looking knee-high fastball for a
strike and a punch out
yeah four-seam fastball true stayed
level at the knees here's the pitch he
breaks his bat bounces that ball to
third and having to dodge the barrel to
bet was the third baseman rendon but he
fielded it right behind
third and easily got to the bag before
the lead runner jeremiah
one ball one strike the count here on
fletcher
and a chopper charged by franco and a
quick
throw over to first boy i'll tell you he
moves
so well here in the top of the fifth the
pitch swung out and missed strike three
so the guy does everything he can homer
he can bunt and he strikes out
and there's two going there's a swing in
a high fly ball
center field pushing kier meyer back but
squares up on it
right at the warning track and makes the
catch
to retire the side so three up three
down for the halos in the fifth we're
halfway through regulation this one
wander franco waits next then austin
meadows the hard the lineup here in the
fifth
went around yeah he did the strikeout
for
canning is his fourth the 3-2 pitch
here's a swing a looping line drive and
that's going to get in
to right center field for a base hit
meadows would take the turn at first but
he'll be satisfied with his second hit
here's the next delivery
fly ball lifted into left center field
and
taylor ward comes in a few feet makes
the catch just above the knees
and that will end the inning second and
third with two gone glaciers been really
good with runners in scoring position
the 2-2 pitch swing and a miss he
struck him out he gets iglesias to go
chasing
he couldn't get it and mchugh is able to
strand runners
at second and third the rays got three
runs two earned in five
innings against canning and now suarez
ground ball by the mound and
everybody's going to be safe joran's
reaching down
they've actually slowed that thing down
and by the time rendon could get there
there was no play anywhere so here's the
switch hitting catcher francisco mejia
now
sends it on the ground to iglesias to
fletcher for one the
easy double play great call on that one
matt
getting that ground ball at an infielder
for two
lefty lefty matchup the pitch he got him
swinging
chased that one a fastball struck him
out and
suarez does a good job they had their
first two get hits in the inning but
they fail to score
leaving a runner at third base diaz
enjoy a board with one gun
meadows pops it up
oh no
[Applause]
everybody saved rendon was going out
as though he was going to make an
over-the-shoulder grab
he peeled off for ward who was coming in
but i think
ward thought that anthony was going to
make the catch pretty good base running
though to be able to get there anyhow it
was a close play
and now after a first and second nobody
out here on the seventh
have a bases loaded situation 1-1 oh
and lau is hit by the pitch and that
will force home the goya
run hit by the pitch scoring diaz
and diego castillo enters this game yeah
putting in the hands of castillo going
out for his 29th appearance
era at just around a three and a half 28
in the third
innings strikeout to walk 39-9 the
one-two pitch
swing and a miss he struck him out in
the race win
and the rays hold off the angels in the
opener of this three-game series
and beat the halos for the fifth
straight time here in 2021